one thing that fascinates me is that
we're spending so much time with the
internet and we're searching online and
when I wrote my book I brain I was
amazed that no one had studied directly
what happens to the brain when it
searches online so we decided to do that
we did we did that study and we use
functional MRI to measure brain function
from moment to moment miss area and we
use functional MRI to measure the neural
circuits how they were behaving from
moment to moment while people searched
online and it was quite an interesting
study we found that older people who
searched online for the first time that
their brains really didn't activate that
much in fact their brains look very
similar to how the brain looks when it
reads a book page but older people who
had previous experience searching online
had a much greater degree of activity in
the brain when they searched online in
the functional MRI scanner in fact it
was a two-fold increase in activity so
that suggested so that finding suggested
to us that maybe the brain is exercising
when it's searching online so to
understand that better we did a part two
of that study we took these internet
naive people and we said to them okay we
want you to practice searching online
and they practice doing it for a week
just an hour a day and we had a very
interesting result and that was in a
matter of just a week we saw significant
increase in neural circuitry not
randomly throughout the brain but in the
frontal lobe areas that control
short-term memory and control
decision-making so the headline was
Google is making a smart I don't know if
it's making a smart but it is increasing
our ability to search online more
effectively and in fact tweaking those
frontal circuits that control some of
the mental tasks that we need to search
online now whether it's
it's helping us with short-term memory
outside of the searching task or with
decision making when we get offline we
don't know that and it would be
interesting to study